wir kommen zu unserer letzten
zuschauerfrage die kam per e-mail rein
vom monteur tobias schirnhofer aus
bayern
er schreibt ich habe im november eine
eintägige private schulung in berlin
ich habe da eine übernachtung muss ich
nach meiner rückkehr in münchen oder in
bayern in quarantäne
ich fürchte fast ja weil das ist jetzt
keine berufliche geschichte man hält
sich einem risikogebiet auf dann wenn
man zurückkehrt muss man das ja angeben
und dann kommt noch hinzu das ist auch
noch eine weile hin ich fürchte fast
dass das so sein wird
genau seine heilpraktiker schulung und
natürlich das klingt jetzt nicht
unbedingt auf berufe berufspendler gibt
es darum wieder ausnahmen das heißt also
wenn ich wirklich beruflich zwingend
dahin fand man muss sich halt nicht in
quarantäne
aber so dieser unterschied ist halt
nicht so einfach oder eben es wird eben
im grunde genommen will man ja diesen
grenzüberschreitenden verkehr gar nicht
der soll ja sozusagen verhindert werden
und deswegen ist das ja auch so ein
bisschen kompliziert das ist ja
vielleicht auch manchmal gar nicht so
unbedingt ungewollt denn es soll ja im
grunde genommen am ende des tages soll
im moment immer noch jeder quasi zu
hause bleiben unter sich bleiben
man soll nicht feiern und dergleichen
und dergleichen mann soll natürlich auch
nicht urlaubstrip machen kein
wochenendtrip man das ist ja sozusagen
die grundforderung die hinter allem
besteht und wenn man jetzt einen
privaten ausflug macht sind die regeln
viel schärfer als wenn man einen
beruflichen ausflug macht oder eine
berufliche fahrt weil man eben sagt ja
dass berufliche muss ja auch noch
irgendwie weitergehen denn das land die
wirtschaft müssen ja nach weiterhin
laufen das muss ja ebenfalls
funktionieren das ist eine ambivalenz
und deswegen kann man sagen im
beruflichen sind eher noch dinge erlaubt
die eben den privaten schauen nicht mehr
erlaubt sind ja wirklich ein volles
programm vielen dank an camp kennst dann
wirklich sehr kompakte information
ich habe auch selbst eine menge gelernt
liebe zuschauer wenn sie fragen haben zu
diesem komplex können sie uns natürlich
weiterhin schicken aber auch ganz
normale probleme sie haben ein
nachbarschaftsstreit sie ärgert sich
über ihren chef wie ist das rechtlich
bei beim thema reisen ich habe probleme
mit dem und dem anbieter alles diese
themen interessieren uns und schicken
sie uns ganz einfach wie so viele
zuschauer das auch getan hat ein handy
video an 01 71 9 59 22 114 whatsapp geht
das alles ganz einfach oder klassisch
per e mail an spar folks at bild.de und
ich freue mich dann schon in der
nächsten sendung auf ihre videos und wir
erklären ihre probleme und versuchen
ihnen zu helfen das ist unser
versprechen ich freue mich auf die
nächste sendung mit ihnen bis dahin ihre
neuer spar fox tschüss